was hat sie denn konkret gemacht was
wird ihm vorgeworfen laut
vernehmungsprotokoll geht es um terror
propaganda weil er in einem artikel
unter anderem geschrieben hat das zitat
erdogan mittels eines referendums seiner
diktatur macht verleihen wird die tat
ende so ich habe den satz 100 mal
gelesen aber ich finde keinen einzigen
fehler meine damen und herren und new
zealand hervor dass in einem weiteren
artikel einen alten witz zitieren ich
könnte in diesem hoch wird bei diesen
witz im original oder auf deutsch
vorlesen aber ich habe mich dann
entschieden auf türkisch kommt noch viel
lustiger
[Musik]
kommt mir war nicht schlecht oder jetzt
mal ehrlich